bonsoir françois merci d'être avec nous
entendre et vient de nous le dire
c'était certainement un voyage davantage
scrutées par les observateurs par les
adversaires politiques et les alliés
politiques de joe biden peut-être un peu
moins par les américains eux mêmes il
n'empêche que retenez-vous de ce ses
premiers pas si j'ose dire en tant que
président américain joe biden à
l'international plutôt une réussite
selon vous alors comme peu comme
stéphanie va transporter l'a dit avec
beaucoup de justesse c'est pas un match
de foot
donc ça veut dire que la différence est
qu'un match de foot on connaît donc il
ya un vainqueur il ya au moins match nul
mais on le sait au bout de 90 minutes
et là on ne sait pas là il va falloir
attendre les historiens donc il va
falloir attendre plusieurs années avant
de savoir qu'est-ce que ça véritablement
a produit qu'est ce que ça a produit
dans la relation entre les etats-unis et
l'europe
qu'est ce que ça a produit dans la
relation entre les etats-unis et la
russie
il ya que l'avenir qui pourra nous le
dire alors vous avez une dire ben on
aurait mieux fait de pas vous invitez
mais c'est quand même important de
préciser il ya quand même des indices il
ya quand même des indices au moins par
exemple sur la relation entre poutine et
balden si ça s'était mal passé on le
saurait déjà
d'abord parce que il ya une photo d'ap
et qui est sorti on pouvait les deux
hommes riant ensemble se tapant même sur
les puisse cette photo elle n'est pas
anodine si elle sort si elle a été prise
c'est un message très clair que quelque
chose s'est produit le champ lexical
vous avez vu que vladimir poutine a
qualifié jo baydan de professionnels il
a même un peu taclé les médias
américains en dix ans avoue le fait
passer pour un membre ou quelqu'un d'un
peu fragile et un peu âgées
j'ai trouvé très en forme et puis il
avait même dit avant sa date pas ça date
pas de la rencontre lille avait dit sur
nbc il ya quelques il ya quelques jours
que donald k donald trump lui était
impulsif
alors évidemment les républicains
apprécieront mais ça veut dire que du
côté demi à poté dans se dit que
finalement mieux vaut peut-être un
président démocrate
avec un sénat légèrement démocrate et
une chambre des représentants démocrates
qui sont un peu plus amène vis-à-vis de
la russie
qu'un président donald trump qui
paraissait vouloir engager une
réconciliation forte une relation
personnelle entre les deux hommes qui
semblait bonne et puis finalement avec
des sénateurs républicains et une
chambre des représentants républicains
extrêmement dur contre contre la russie
et puis il ya aussi des annonces alors
c'est pas les 99 dossiers de dissensions
qui auront été réglées évidemment mais
il ya quelques annonces en retour les
ambassadeurs
le fait de travailler sur la
cybersécurité le fait de travailler
aussi sur la réglementation des
armements nucléaires
ce sont des annonces importantes qui
montre que quelque chose s'est produit
dans la relation entre la russie et les
etats-unis et le président américain il
ya intérêt parce que finalement que veut
joe biden
là il veut simplement que ne se produise
pas eu d'alliance très forte entre la
russie et la chine
parce que il ne veut pas que la guerre
froide hier avec la russie ne un
handicap en quelque sorte sa guerre
froide a mené 2 aujourd'hui et de demain
contre la chine
effectivement c'est ça la clé françois
durpaire la chine qui est d'une certaine
manière pas l'ennemi commun mais en tout
cas le vrai danger vient de là et il ya
eu cette prise
réel de conscience si si vous regardez
c'était famille ce qui a été dit au
sommet de l'otan se met le temps qu'ils
auraient à l'origine j'allais dire de la
création d'autant c'était la guerre
froide et c'est l opposition à la russie
soviétique là c'est vraiment la chine
qui est visé c'est dans le texte de la
conférence c'est le défi structurel
la chine est très clairement joe biden
il était venu en europe pour deux
raisons la première raison c'était de
dire on a cette taxe de 15% sur des
entreprises mondialisées et ça c'est
important pour moi parce que je fais de
la diplomatie pour les classes moyennes
américaines
c'est un petit peu l'héritage de date
krumm pas de montrer une sorte de
patriotisme diplomatique
et puis le deuxième point c'était de
créer un front commun européen américain
contre la chine qui puisse fonctionner
dans les instances internationales on
pense bientôt g20 on pense à l'om c est
donc c'était l'objectif maintenant est
ce que ça a produit quelque chose on ne
sait pas véritablement encore on a bien
vu que joe biden on regarde fortement du
côté allemande pour l'instant le
partenaire européen parce que on parle
beaucoup de multilatéralisme la vérité
c'est qu'il ya à la fois de lüthi
latéral isme que joe biden doit discuter
avec le conseil européen avec la
commission européenne mais que c'est
aussi un multi bilatéralisme l'europe et
ça c'est le désavantage structurelles et
institutionnelles de laura c'est
toujours des états désunis d'europe face
aux états unis d'amérique et puis il ya
aussi un des ventes
un des avantages européen sur ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui au niveau de la
pandémie mondiale
les etats-unis sont déjà dans le monde
d'après et l'europe est encore un peu
entre deux eaux
vous avez vu pour la france aujourd'hui
on en être les masques les américains
c'est déjà il y à il ya plusieurs jours
relance économique très forte
et puis c'est la première puissance
mondiale l'europe n'est pour l'instant
qu'une somme d'économies donc ça veut
dire que bien sûr c'est un
multilatéralisme qui se remet en place
mais diriger l'idée par les états unis
est dans le viseur c'est pas
principalement la russie dans le viseur
c'est principalement la chine les
partisans de joe biden ont salué le
retour d'une vraie diplomatie est ce que
c'est c'est véritablement le cas
aujourd'hui quand on voit cette première
prestation de dob joe biden à
l'international oui il ya deux mots qui
ont qui ont été les mots un peu répété
par la maison blanche pour que ça
finisse par rentrer à l'intérieur des
des médias et on n'est pas obligé de les
reprendre à notre compte mais c'est
stabilité et prévisibilité
ça a été repris aussi par un certain
nombre de dirigeants européens
ça a été aussi leurs prix par vladimir
poutine qui a dit il y a quelqu'un de
professionnel
le précédent était impulsif là on a
quelqu'un de stable et professionnels
alors si la diplomatie ça veut dire que
on a en face de nous quelqu'un qui va
essayer de préparer en amont
on a vu par exemple la rencontre entre
le premier ministre britannique et le
président américain quelques heures
avant leur rencontre pour aplanir un peu
les difficultés si c'est essayer aussi
de créer une alliance sur la confiance 6
et essayait bien de tenir un peu la
parole - sur quelques jours on se
rappelle de donald trump qui repartaient
des conférences internationales avec
d'un côté la maison blanche qui faisait
qu'ils avaient à un discours
et puis de l'autre côté le président
américain qui twittait complètement
autre chose
là ce n'est plus le cas là c'est en
quelque sorte quelque chose diplomatie
plus discrète
alors plus discrète mais néanmoins
extrêmement intense parce que vous avez
vu que s'est tournée européenne
c'est le temps c'est le g7 finances
c'est le g7 c'est le conseil européen la
commission européenne ce et voir tous
les chefs d'état européens qui compte
c'est la lumière coûtait donc on est à
une sorte de comme si on avait eu une
fringale de diplomatie pendant quatre
ans avec denain train que joe biden
tente de rattraper et finalement
l'importance de la russie on la voit
bien en aux etats unis puisque c'était
ça qui était attendu pas seulement par
les républicains mais par l'ensemble des
américains de salles et de mike cahill
ont connu la guerre froide pour les plus
anciens et donc évidemment ils vont être
plus sensible aux chocs des images et à
ce qui s'est produit avec vladimir
poutine que ces multi rencontre avec les
chefs d'état et chefs de gouvernement
européens
mais finalement tous les américains ont
dans la tête un peu la phrase de keith
singer vous rappelez de 1970 sous il
disait l'europe c'est quel numéro de
téléphone l'europe donc les beaucoup
d'américains ne s'y retrouvent pas
tellement dans la politique européenne
en revanche ils comprennent bien qui via
la russie et que c'est une victoire pour
vladimir poutine rien que l'organisation
d'un sommet d'ailleurs c'est ce que les
républicains ont reproché à joe biden
d'avoir offert ce se met à l admire
poutine
rien que la rencontre est une est une
réussite alors après pour ce qu'elle a
produit sur le long terme il faudra
évidemment attendre je vous ai dit dans
des années historiens nous dira on va
quand même voir dans les semaines qui
viennent
qu'est ce qui va se passer sur le
dossier iranien qu'est ce qui va se
passer sur le dossier syrien
qu'est ce qui va se passer sur le
dossier chinois qu'est ce qui va se
passer sur le dossier des sanctions
américaines contre la russie tous ces
dossiers vont permettre de voir si
effectivement des lignes ont bougé et si
quelque chose est en train de se
produire dans la relation entre la
russie et les etats-unis qui
convenons-en et vladimir poutine et joe
biden était
d'accord sur ce point est au plus bas
d'ailleurs la réussite du sommet elle
est liée à une chose j'ai terminé par là
c'est que pendant toute la semaine qui a
précédé le sommet on a fait redescendre
le niveau d'attentes en disant oh la la
n'attendez pas grand chose de ce sommet
on était quasiment sûr de pouvoir dire
va finalement ça s'est pas mal passé
merci beaucoup en tout cas françois
durpaire historien spécialiste des états
unis pour cette analyse complète merci à
vous